your first draft how much weight do you
let it carry and then how much time you
know you talked about giving time and
space to actually reading the story
doing other things trying to forget
about it then coming back what about
with the first draft in what you mean do
I let it sit for a while or how much
weight do you actually how much do you
really obsess over it or you just you
know they called the vomit draft and you
can yeah no I'm not a vomit ER and
mostly I think that when scripts are not
right fundamentally in their first
drafts they never will be hence four
five six riders being called on to
something in service of something that
wasn't right to begin with so you should
get a new take rather than try to make
put a bandaid on something that doesn't
work I wish more weight and more time
were given to first drafts because they
are often the draft that's closest to
something electric whether you're
writing a thriller or a quiet little
movie or a comedy and subsequent drafts
and however long someone works on
something in the end it always ends up
going back to an earlier state when
you've got the right people working on
something it's always in my experience
goes back to its first fundamental state
with improvements
you